el Palacio de Bagdad completamente vacío
y una pregunta en el aire quién
gobernará el Líbano con la salida del
presidente Michelle aún cristiano
maronita y Aliado dejes bola y con el
Primer Ministro interino el musulmán se
unitan allí fuera del país la formación
de un nuevo ejecutivo no se vislumbra
cerca debido en parte a las riñas
internas entre ambos políticos un hecho
sin precedentes desde la Constitución de
creo que las cosas no se arreglarán del
todo en Líbano excepto con el cambio de
la clase política tradicional actual que
todavía controla el 70% del parlamento y
por lo tanto impide la correcta
transición democrática creo que tarde o
temprano antes de que expire el mandato
del actual parlamento habrá elecciones
parlamentarias anticipadas
la configuración política del Líbano y
la designación de su mandatario pasa
porque el candidato obtenga Al menos una
mayoría de dos tercios de los 128
miembros del parlamento el presidente
siempre debe ser un cristiano el Primer
Ministro un musulmán sunita y el
presidente del parlamento musulmán cita
el parlamento libanés está dividido en
dos bandos uno liderado por hezbollar
respaldado por Irán y Rusia y otro más
cercano a occidente y las potencias
regionales unitas a esto se suma la gran
cantidad de candidatos a la presidencia
desde las últimas elecciones generales
en mayo no se formó ningún gobierno tal
vacío de poder está ocurriendo mientras
líbanos se enfrenta a una situación
socioeconómica en deterioro la
volatilidad institucional agravada por
la inestabilidad económica plantearía
graves riesgos para el Líbano y su
población en medio de este vacío de
poder con un gobierno interino que no
puede tomar decisiones legales la
sociedad libanesa está colapsando y
reclama desde hace años una nueva clase
política el 80% de la población vive por
debajo del nivel de pobreza y la moneda
perdió el 95% de su valor desde 2019